das muss deutsch gesagt ein irrer sein
der ein kernkraftwerk hier unter
beschuss nimmt beziehungsweise auch
mutwillig
dort versucht zu zerstören während
heftiger kämpfe ukrainischer und
russischen streitkräfte ist bei europas
größtem atomkraftwerk ein feuer
ausgebrochen ein trainings gebäude
außerhalb der anlage des akw historische
brenne teilte die ukrainische
staatssicherheit in der nacht zu freitag
mit mein name ist martinz ich bin als
professor an der technischen hochschule
brandenburg tätig auf dem gebiet der
berg der sicherheit und kritischen
infrastrukturen ansonsten bin ich ja
sachverständiger vielfach unterwegs im
auftrag von ezios bzw auch verschiedene
regierungen zur frage der sicherheit von
kernkraftwerken
insbesondere im kernkraftwerken umgebung
von deutschland
[Musik]
dieser standort in der ukraine
ich hab den russischen namen noch das
ist sushi
besteht aus insgesamt sechs
reaktorblöcken es handelt sich da um
sogenannte druckwasserreaktoren das sind
anlagen die im grunde weltweit in
betrieb sind und auch aktuell gebaut
werden was man eben sagen muss dass die
anlagen wie sie jetzt dort im betrieb
sind dass die
auslegung zeiten der 17 jahre
zurückgehen nicht mehr den heute
gültigen aktuellen
sicherheitsanforderungen entsprechen
das ist ein granaten einschlag auf dem
kaff ex gelände
passiert aber ohne auswirkungen auf die
anlage also fakt ist es die anlage gegen
kriegerische einwirkung nicht ausgelegt
ist das
keine anlage weltweit ist gegen
einwirkung aus kriegerischen einwirkung
ausgelegt das heißt also sie können die
anlage nicht
mit einer rakete beschossen
dann würde die anlage
ernsthaften schaden nehmen das ist
einfach so dass sind mann verletzte nahm
mit ethische grundsätze ja denn die man
es nicht vorstellbar dass eine anlage
mit kriegerischen mitteln angegriffen
würde gern kraftwerksanlage
allerdings das problem sein kann ist sie
kennen ja die kraftwerksanlage ist die
kuppel dort die man immer sieht wenn man
kernkraftwerk dort abbildet bzw auch sie
aus meter dickem stahlbeton
dort innerhalb dieser
dieses diesem containments befindet sich
eben der reaktor mit dem reaktorkern
und dann ist es klar dass dieser
reaktorkern auch wenn er abgeschaltet
wird
noch eine lange zeit gekühlt werden muss
und hier ist eigentlich
eine kohl gefährdung möglich dass man
diese so genannte kühlkette wärme muss
ja von vom kern in nach draußen
transportiert werden wenn diese
kühlkette unterbrochen wird also durch
militärische eindrücken zum beispiel
also dort bestimmte wärmetauscher
beziehungsweise auch pumpen so zerstört
werden dass die nicht mehr wirksam sein
würden dann hätten wir natürlich ein
riesen problem dann käme es im ernstfall
im ungünstigsten fall im zu einer
beschädigung des reaktorkerns mit den
entsprechenden freisetzungen und den
problemen die ist da ausgeben
ja es ist heute die auslegungs
anforderung dass kernkraftwerke gegen
flugzeugabsturz natürlich mit einer
bestimmten größe man hat immer ausgelegt
in kenntnis was für flieger es eben gibt
dagegen sind die kernkraft ecke
ausgelegt das heißt wenn da hat
tatsächlich ein flugzeug abstürzt
beziehungsweise auch bewusst dahin
gesteuert wird ist
die anlage gegen flugzeugabsturz im
prinzip ausgelegt und ja im prinzip
ausgelegt das muss man sagen nur es ist
eben nicht ausgelegt
gegenhalten wenn das raketenbeschuss auf
die anlage statt
diese vorstellungskraft habe ich
eigentlich nicht wer ich bin groß
geworden mit kern perfekte über die
gesamte zeit der entwicklung von den
ersten anlagen die mehr noch versuchten
anlagen waren bis jetzt wo moderne
anlagen produziert werden die höchsten
schutz anfang genügen sollen da kann man
sich nicht vorstellen dass jemand hier
bewusst eine anlage versuch zu zerstören
mit einfallen sie müssen sich auch
vorstellen dass diejenigen die dies tun
wollen ja selbst das ist ja
selbstmörderisch wenn ich daran gehe die
freisetzung die dann stattfinden würde
würde sich ja eben auch diejenigen die
das veranlassen selbst aus